[Musique]
premiers pas du premier ministre désigné
françois legault sur la scène
internationale vous venez de le voir en
présence de paul kagame le président du
rwanda et la candidate comme secrétaire
général de l'organisation internationale
de la francophonie pour succéder à
michaëlle jean
louise mushikiwabo qui est ministre des
affaires étrangères à leur foi on veut
faire le point avec rires et de kerchove
ancien diplomate pour voir où en est la
diplomatie québécoise et canadienne dans
cette dans ce feuilleton ferry bonsoir
bienvenue à 24,60 parce que les
dernières les dernières nouvelles que
nous avons aujourd'hui par le
porte-parole de madame j'en sais qu'un
consensus pour une candidature suppose
un débat ce débat-là doit se faire il
devra se faire dans les heures qui
viennent mais vous venez d'entendre
monsieur legault féliciter madame
mushikiwabo avant même qu'il y ait ce
débat qu'est ce que vous proposez de
cette situation mais vous me pardonnerez
pour une fois d'être un peu brutale moi
qui ne le suis jamais je vous dirais que
je suis profondément choquée par
l'inélégance de la façon dont le premier
ministre du canada a géré cette affaire
en plus de ça une incohérence en matière
de politique étrangère et je dirais
presque une méconnaissance des usages et
des habitudes et de la façon de faire en
francophonie savent touche presque aux
valeurs même dont on parle en
francophonie
alors je crois que c'est un c'est déjà
un élément assez important la façon dont
ça a été fait car on devrait en principe
être en mesure de donner à la secrétaire
général ou le secret adjoint de la
francophonie à deux mandats comme ça
c'est fait toujours dans le passé mais
il ya aussi si vous voulez une une
dimension kid qui est aussi cette espèce
de tentative de rejeter madame jean sous
prétexte de certaines des écarts et un
courrier aux inconstances que l' on les
reconnaît mais qui a été dénoncée
surtout par le canada et par le québec
notamment par le journal de montréal
pour des raisons qui parfois ont un sous
entendu politique mais les chefs d'état
africains ne se sont jamais plaints de
madame jean peut-être que la chaussure
de monsieur abdou diouf était un peu
grande aaa rat chaussée pour elle mais
elle a fait quand même un boulot assez
satisfaisant elle a deux ouvert des
pistes notamment en matière de l'emploi
des jeunes et la promotion de la femme
donc c'est pas comme si madame gens
étaient tout à coup une catastrophe et
c'est là où vraiment j'ai un problème
majeur en tant qu'étrangère alors
commençons par votre première remarque
l'inélégance si on veut abandonner ou
larguées quelqu'un est ce qu ont atteint
la veille du largage la veille de la
conclusion de deux sommets pour larguer
la personne est ce qu'il ya pas y avait
pas moyen de faire autrement plus tôt
mais c'est d'autant plus incohérent que
encore tout récemment il n'ya même pas
très longtemps la candidature de madame
jean continuer à être soutenus moi j'ai
vu madame jean au moins de mai et le
gouvernement est l'avait encore soutenue
au moment où on annonçait justement la
candidature de madame mimi chicago gamot
donc autrement dit il ya eu un espèce de
coup de vent
il fait d'une façon vous savez c'est le
bureau de madame joly qui permet à des
journalistes of de rigueur
un homme de rigueur passablement bruyant
de dire vous savez nous lâchons c'est
vraiment d'une d'une incorrection mais
c'est en plus de sa stupide sur le plan
politique un joueur mais en revanche est
ce que vous comprenez la pugnacité de
michaëlle jean ou son entêtement à ne
pas céder devant ce qui pêche des
anguilles mais ce qui paraît ce
consensus mais monsieur legault a
abandonné ou vont alors de premièrement
je n'appellerais pas ça de l'entêtement
je trouve qu'elle a droit de continuer à
être candidate ça c'est le premier point
est gelée déjà critiqué sur certains des
déboires et état mais je crois qu'elle a
le droit premièrement deuxièmement kiri
donne ce droit là parce que c'est
l'appui des pays
c'est l'appui du canada normalement
puisqu'il n'y avait pas de consensus
africain en 2014 bon ça c'est on a on a
peut-être madame jean par défaut parce
que les africains n'ont pas de consensus
mais cette histoire de consensus et une
est une vraiment vraiment alors ça c'est
vraiment un esclandre parce que pourquoi
d'abord consensus ne pas dire soumission
premièrement deuxièmement il ya le coup
d'état de l'union africaine quand kagame
à la toute fin de la réunion de
l'organisation unité africaine a dit
à propos j'ai l'intention de soumettre
madame michu cadeaux comme candidate
pour la succession à madame genre bad
pas d'objection beau mais on a frappé
sur le marteau ça se fait pas dans le
contexte africain troisièmement
troisièmement généralement les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement africains
aiment débattre des shows dans un dans
un climat de la lèze de 200 de sincérité
en même temps de sérénité mais ils n'ont
pas eu l'occasion de débattre à loyat
est justement ils veulent pouvoir
débattre non pas d'une opposition
fabriqués par la france et par kagamé
mais discuter honnêtement de la
candidature de l'une et de l'autre et
d'en débattre
alors là on essaie de mettre un bâillon
sur cette procédure je trouve ça
vraiment mais totalement inacceptable là
un des arguments de madame jean évoqué
depuis plusieurs mois c'est le fait que
le rwanda est un pays autoritaire pour
d'autres une dictature il y aurait de la
répression politique assassine apple et
tout ça sauf que c'est une question que
madame jean n'a jamais soulevé à l'égard
des pays membres de la francophonie il
ya plusieurs dictatures dans cette
organisation là on ne donnerait pas
comme on dit ici hd ou chrétiens
l'absolution sans confession non je vous
dirais qu'en réponse à sac c'est que
kagame c'est à dire kagame a énormément
sur le corps après tout c 'est pas le
rwanda qui a été le pays le plus
pacifique sud à fait d'accord avec vous
qu'il y a qu il ya des gros vilain dans
l'andante francophonie met dedans mais
madame jean finalement c'est davantage
occupé de questions économiques est
jeune et tout ça que de dénoncer
différents pays et c'est là la
différence et c'est là le problème
madame j'en ai pape diouf abdou diouf
quand il y avait un problème en afrique
prenez le téléphone avec laura et
l'autorité qu'il avait réussi à atténuer
les tensions mais ça n'a jamais monsieur
diouf aussi à dénoncer mais vous savez
l'article l'article 5 de la déclaration
de bamako qui permet justement de
prendre des mesures concrètes
ça a été invoquée relativement gr g
rarement mais le vrai problème aussi de
kagame s'est pas seulement que c'est un
dictateur c'est aussi qu'ils imposaient
l'anglais comme langue officielle a
renoncé le aux français comment est ce
qu a pas quelque chose de profondément
incohérent quand on choisit une personne
de la francophonie d'un pays africain
qui a renoncé à la langue française ya
quelque chose de totalement incohérent
dans cette affaire-là école alors il ya
aussi oui oui en mauricie a des raisons
géopolitiques qui explique que le canada
veuille se ranger du côté de la france
et l'union africaine
comment expliquer que monsieur legault
lui ne se range aussi on n'a pas de
politique africaine n'a pas de politique
vraiment internationale ou québec
alors comment expliquer qu'il sait de si
rapidement au point de féliciter madame
même mushikiwabo déjà oui c'est assez
c'est assez amusant de sa part mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez il rentre en
scène
il n'a pas encore le dossier au complet
peut-être qu'il n'a pas beaucoup
apprécié non plus compte tenu son passé
peut-être certaines orientations de
madame jean et ma foi ça ne sert à rien
de se mettre en but contre le premier
ministre du canada qui lui-même vient de
lâcher la prise je trouve que c'est ce
n'est pas de bonne guerre ce n'est pas
élégant mais je vous je lui reproche à à
lui beaucoup moins qu on ne reprochera à
monsieur trudeau le site idée mais on on
dépasse le temps qui nous est donnée je
parlais de d'entraînement ténacité de
madame jean reste c'est en persistant
son droit individuel à elle de vouloir
rester en piste
est ce que ça ne nuit pas au canada ce
qui ne devrait pas faire passer
l'intérêt du canada qu'il a très bien
servi comme gouverneure générale et
jeter dessus d'une correction qui lui
paie une pension imposable dois je dire
241 1000 $ par année à vie est ce qu est
ce qu elle doit pas faire partie les
intérêts du canada avant les siens moi
je vous dirais que l'intérêt du canada
ma chère à marie c'est l'intérêt de la
politique étrangère du canada
francophonie et c'est de ne pas donner à
le donner la leçon son vote à quelqu'un
d'un pays qui est qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas du tout recommandables et dont
et dont la première ministre de
l'enseignement il ya vraiment quelle que
soit il ya aussi la sphère de monsieur
macron qui essayent de littéralement
dicter la conduite et les leaders
africains ne sont pas contents de ça il
n'y a pas de consensus et une fiction et
je crois que vraiment on a vraiment très
mal engagé et moi j'ai honte de cette
francophonie là si c'est celle que j'ai
servi dans le camp merci fait rire de
cas comme vous nous avez apporté un
point de vue différent de ceux des tirs
en panne ou qu'on a entendu depuis
quelques jours et cesseront
on recherchait merci beaucoup de plaisir
à mai